[music] The
Main Investigation Department of the
Investigative Committee of Russia initiated a
criminal case in connection with the incident
on the Crimean bridge, according to preliminary
information, this morning on the
automobile part of the Crimean bridge from the
side of the Taman peninsula, a
truck was blown up, which resulted in
the ignition of seven fuel tanks of the
railway train following in the
direction of the Crimean  peninsula as a
result, two car spans partially collapsed
[music]
as a result of an
emergency  day, a
government commission will work with my
participation, which will determine the degree of
damage, and today the
ways of restoring and the time for
restoring the roadway will be worked out, and,
accordingly, if  necessary The
railway component
[music]
No one knows to
walk the
moon and let's say checks checks checks
it's done so we're afraid
it's hard to scare those who
have already lost someone in this war